Biden also could not pronounce the name
of a new monument that he is
inaugurating proud to use my Authority
Under the Antiquities act to establish
the and I I want you to know it's a big
deal The
Havana may I I'm having trouble thank
you
I got it yeah I don't think so this is a
really and I want you to know it's a
really big deal the thing that we're
doing that I'm just reading about now
we're inaugurating we're naming this
mountain this new National Monument as
uh
uh what he was trying to say is the Avi
quoi AME which is the Mojave name for
Spirit Mountain in southern Nevada this
site apparently is sacred to tribes
including the payuri and the chemawavi
and it provides a habitat for a bunch of
different species